I diet recommendations for you say no to bone broth but I have regular broth
homemade or stock store bought the reason why we say no to bone broth is because
so understand bone broth is typically made by steeping bones chicken
bones or beef bones for a long period of time and your the whole idea is your
dry the nutrients out of the bone so bone broth is really big in what's called
the gaps diet and it was very popular but a number of years became very
popular a number of years ago it still is fairly popular to help heal the gut
using bone broth so a lot of people were into making their own bone broth their
cooking a chicken take it all the mean off event cooking the bones for you
know a couple days to make a broth out of that and then drinking then filtering it
out and just drinking the broth to help heal the gut why does that help heal
the gut because it has a very high concentration of glutamine in it and glutamine
El glutamine the amino acid really helps with growth so when you drink high
concentration of glutamine in bone broth or you take a gut healing supplement that
has three four or five grams of glutamine you can really help heal a damaged
gut and that can be very beneficial because El glutamine really stimulates
especially epithelial cell reproduction and you'll reproduce new cells helping
heal the gut well if you haven't especially if you have an epithelial based
cancer you're stimulating growth so glutamine is a pathway of cancer cell
growth so you don't want to do bone broth in general now there's nothing wrong with
I made soup should I not make soup because I make soup with the whole chicken and
I boil it and then I take the meat off the bone well usually you take the bone out
then and you put the meat back in the pot and you add your vegetables and
suction then you eat the soup so you're not getting this super high concentration
of glutamine if your purposely making bone broth the idea in the whole purpose of
making bone broth is to draw as much glutamine out of the bone as possible so that
is healing to your gut so no whether you buy store-bought bone broth or you buy
whole or you make homemade bone broth it's really a dough to bone broth but you can
if soup just don't make bone broth